il y a trente ans l'état les a expulsés
pour faire de leurs terres un parc
national destiné aux touristes mais
aujourd'hui ils ont gagné leur procès et
ont enfin le droit de revenir les
anciens se souviennent encore de leur
expulsion
on ne nous a même pas donné un ultimatum
on nous a expulsé par la force ils ont
dit vous avez 24 heures pour partir sans
même nous dire où aller
si vous ne partez pas on roulera vos
maisons on détruira votre bétail et vous
irez en prison
une humiliation qu'ils n'oublieront
jamais ces hommes avaient tout perdu
pour pouvoir laisser les touristes
profiter de ce spectacle unique
une source d'eau potable vital pour ce
peuple d'éleveurs
[Musique]
et pour fêter cet événement ils sont des
milliers de guerriers en de roye
revêtus de leurs armes à descendre vers
le lac
plus personne ne peut les arrêter
maintenant ces sommes sont les pionniers
d'un mouvement de retour des tribus sur
leurs terres ancestrales
[Musique]
comme les massaï les andrei veulent être
reconnus comme les propriétaires de leur
territoire et c'est ce qu'ils viennent
d'obtenir au terme d'un long procès
contre le kenya une première dans toute
l'histoire du pays
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la fête au pays des
zones de ruck
les femmes font résonner dans la chaleur
sèche de la vallée du rift les chants
traditionnels
ils sont près de 10000 venus de toutes
les collines où on les a si longtemps
exilé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les zones de reuil sont peut-être moins
connus que les massaï et pourtant ces
fiers guerriers ont fait plier le
gouvernement kényan
[Musique]
le jeune homme au milieu en rose c'est
nelson pour cet éleveur de 22 ans c'est
le plus beau jour de sa vie
qu'ils avaient les portables c'est une
journée très importante pour nous une
journée historique surtout pour notre
génération
le kenya
toutes les minorités du pays qui sont
opprimés par le même gouvernement
qu'il est possible de gagner
ils vont suivre notre stratégie ratée
elle est aussi devant les tribunaux sans
aucune ethnie ne pourra plus être
sacrifiés au nom du tourisme cette
victoire les ondes ans ila doivent en
grande partie à cette femme blanche
cynthia mort elle une avocate canadienne
pendant des années elle s'est battue
pour eux aujourd'hui les endort il lui
offre la récompense suprême ils font
d'elle l'une des leurs
maintenant nous allons baigneurs cynthia
et l'accueillir comme un membre de notre
peuple
wegnez tout
aux tailles
disons que c'est un peu compliqué pour
moi aujourd'hui parce que je suis
enceinte donc mon mari tenait absolument
à ce que chien tom et son fils ils sont
à mon sens les dons qu'ils ont gagné le
premier cas devant la commission
africaine
qui reconnaissait les droits des peuples
autochtones en afrique c'est de
reconnaître les gens qui avaient besoin
de l'accès à la terre ancestrale pour
leur survie culturelle économique et
social un enfant ils auront droit à
gérer disons-le à la réserve touristique
et en bénéficier économiquement
l'avocate canadienne est assailli de
toutes parts par les andes de roj ils
veulent toucher leur sauveuse on
retrouve nelson qui lui aussi lui promet
de ne jamais l'oublier
[Applaudissements]
les cérémonies se poursuivent sous une
chaleur qui dépasse les 40 degrés dans
le public certains ne tiennent pas le
choc et perdre connaissance
trop d'émotions et de soleil pour cette
jeune femme qui est vite prise en main
les discours s'enchaînent dans une
ferveur inouïe les revendications des
andes aux russes sont claires retrouver
un libre accès aux rives du lac et
surtout être reconnus comme les
propriétaires à part entière du site et
en retirer les dividendes
aujourd'hui les endort y ont retrouvé
leur fierté et veulent le faire savoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont la preuve vivante que les
minorités du kenya se réveille et
réclament leur dû le tourisme à
l'ancienne et les safaris qui privilégie
les animaux face aux populations locales
c'est bien fini les anciens vont enfin
pouvoir retourner sur la terre de leurs
ancêtres
c'est leur victoire et personne ne
pourra leur enlever